foreign
you will learn how to use proximity
searching in PubMed
proximity searching allows you to search
for terms that are close to each other
for example Define variations of a
phrase
let's say you were searching for
variations of the phrase Healthcare
rationing
you might want to find rationing
Healthcare Healthcare rationing
rationing of health care or rationing
strategies in healthcare
proximity searching in PubMed can be
used to supplement medical subject
heading searches
in PubMed you can use proximity
searching to search for multiple words
appearing in any order within a
specified distance of one another in the
title or title and Abstract fields
to search for the word rationing and the
word Healthcare with no words in between
in the title or abstract fields of the
PubMed records you would type into the
search box quote rationing Healthcare
end quote Open Bracket Tia B colon tilde
0 in bracket
your results include records with
rationing health care and Healthcare
rationing in the title or abstract
to search for the word rationing and the
word Healthcare with up to one word in
between in the title or abstract fields
of PubMed records you would type into
the search box
quote rationing Health Care end quote
Open Bracket
tiab
colon tilde one in bracket
this would add to your previous search
phrases like rationing of healthcare and
rationing in health care
to search for the word rationing and the
word Healthcare with up to two words in
between in the title or abstract fields
of PubMed records you would use the same
syntax but instead of one use the number
two
this would add to your previous search
phrases like rationing strategies in
healthcare
using our last example as a template
construct a search for the terms
congenital and defect with up to one
word in between in the title field of
PubMed
the title field can be searched with the
word title in Brackets
your results will have records with the
terms congenital and defect with up to
one word in between in the title field
note that automatic term mapping is not
applied to the terms when you do a
proximity search
for comprehensive searches on biomedical
terms you will want to combine proximity
searching with other techniques to build
your query
for example while this search retrieves
records with the term congenital heart
defect
there are more than 30 more specific
medical subject headings under heart
defects congenital
you would need to include the mesh term
either directly or through automatic
term mapping to include these more
specific terms in your search
proximity searching is a powerful tool
that should be used in combination with
other searches of PubMed
for more about proximity searching in
PubMed see the PubMed user guide
for expert assistance with your PubMed
searches contact your local Health
Sciences librarian